[Music]
this morning on the dish pitmaster Hugh
Mangum born in California his father
held from Texas and first introduced him
to the legendary barbecue of the Lone
Star State he started out as a
professional drummer before heading to
culinary school and work in the kitchens
of acclaimed chefs like John George
in 2011 he melded the barbecue
traditions of Texas and the Carolinas to
create a unique New York style offered
at his first mighty Quinn's location in
Manhattan was a huge hit leading to four
more venues in the New York metro area
and now outlets in Taiwan the
Philippines Japan and Dubai u Mangum
good morning welcome to the dish thank
you guys for having me good morning
that's quite a that's quite an outreach
you know a little schizophrenic in my
approach yes
but the table and the speaking of
schizophrenic has everything that's a
good thing tell us what we're about to
hear we've got a feast for you so I mean
I'll start on your side we have a nice
beverage there which is the our beer our
mighty Quinn's Pilsner we have our sweet
potato casserole which is the next in
line then we've got our sweet corn
fritters with a chili honey sauce then
we have our buttermilk broccoli salad
which is tossed with some bacon some
cranberries and toasted almonds then
we've got our burnin baked beans which
is actually came from my father's Black
IPA recipe for New Year's which we
turned that into the bran and baked
beans at the restaurant then we have our
mac and cheese which we won best mac and
cheese in New York this year Wow and
then we have brisket which is what built
the house brisket sweat you know it
started at Smorgasburg it you know in
Brooklyn with brisket smoking it for 22
hours on our smoker bringing it in and
slicing it to order and that's you know
kind of our marquee meat and then you
know finally we have some pineapple
upside-down cake for you guys if I do
please please enjoy you mentioned
Smorgasburg which is essentially what
it's like a it's like a food street fair
kind of food flea market yes yes and
this started all only six years ago with
you yeah so the the dream started long
before that
but the Smorgasburg was were mighty
Quinn's was officially launched as this
as this brand I was smoking meat in my
driveway and my wife's cousin Adam had
said oh there's this market this wee
market you should do and so I called
them up and did a tasting like well we
have no space in the
we market for you but we're doing an all
food market called Smorgasburg would
you'd be interested yeah I said
absolutely we showed up for the first
day after being afraid that we wouldn't
sell any food we sold out in like 90
minutes and then every week the lines
would get longer and it was just
becoming word-of-mouth and it just
became this kind of I was like a you
know a food flea market version of a
viral sensation and you know the lo and
behold a couple years later
you know with my two partners Christos
and Misha we opened up our first
brick-and-mortar it's amazing though
because even before that you had success
you said the dream started long before
you're having success as a drummer what
was that sort of desire to get into the
culinary world
well success is a relative term so
making a living on tour with The
Wallflowers in Jakob Dylan well yes I
was in the opening act for those guys on
the you know their biggest tour and that
was amazing but you know truth is look
when you're a kid and you're you know
you're into music and you've got like
you know posters a Billy Idol on your
wall going to go on tour is the dream
come true right but making a living and
going on tour two very different things
and making a living as a musician is
much different than actually you know
going out getting a per diem and loving
when you're on tour but then when you
come home you have you know virtually no
money to show for it so I got to live
that dream and it was awesome and you
know I love music and you know my kids
my son's Quinn Lucas and Henry they all
love and it's name comes from your son's
name yes Quinn as my oldest son
restaurants named after Quinn right so
was this kind of a was this like a Hail
Mary pass then the starting to barbecue
well starting the barbecue was a passion
project the Hail Mary was with
Smorgasburg I mean that was I was down
to my last penny basically how did you
end up in Asia though I mean it's
amazing six years later you have places
all across Asia I took a wrong turn
going to the Holland Tunnel
so our first partners in Asia one of the
owners wife happened to be in New York
and tasted the food and she was like we
have to bring them to Asia so they you
know they vetted us we went and visited
them and just made a lot of sense well
we'll have you sign the dish now are you
guys you do let me ask you if you could
have a meal with anyone past or present
who would it be oh my gosh okay so this
is the easiest one I could I can say for
you I would say
it would have to be and this is gonna
get a little sappy I'm lost at but it
would be nice happy okay it would be my
father so my father died two years
before I went to culinary school he
never got to meet my wife he has not
ever obviously met his grandkids to who
they they're very like they feel a
kinship with him yeah so I would say I
would love to share this meal with him
to show him what I've learned and how I
could honor his past I'd also like to
have my mother at the table so my mother
who's also from the Bronx so I've got
New York and me but have my wife my kids
my mom and my dad at a table eating food
that I cooked that would be the dream
come true sounds like a great meal thank
you yeah thank you guys for having me
pleasure thanks so much guys chef Hugh
Mangum
for more on Hugh Mangum and the dish you
can head to our website at CBS this
morning dot-com